ladies and gentlemen please welcome
veteran actor Elijah Wood
if you were a kid and you told your
parents he had seen a man suspended by a
thread over a thousand foot drop or a
group of very strange characters and
Halloween outfits flying through the air
on Christmas Eve or gigantic real live
dinosaurs overturning cars and chasing
scientists they would probably say you
were lying write a vivid imagination or
think you had a bright future a nice
career ahead as a visual effects person
that last choice is what the parents of
these nominees must have thought when
they were kids and they would have been
right these are the nominees for visual
effects in cliffhanger the challenge is
to create a spectacular helicopter crash
without endangering stars John Lithgow
and Sylvester Stallone nominees Neil
crapola John Richardson John Bruno and
Pamela Isley
managed to save the producers a small
fortune by using small versions of the
real thing and the results were a big
smash while the actors of Jurassic Park
are safely filming their scenes alone
dozens of dangerous dinosaurs are being
designed by nominees Dennis Muren Stan
Winston Phil Tippett and Michael and
Terry using live action mechanical
dinosaurs computers and lots of
Hollywood magic they populated Jurassic
Park with the most realistic and
terrifying dinosaurs in film history in
The Nightmare Before Christmas nominees
Pete kasagic Erica laton
Arielle Velasco Shaw and Gordon Baker
used live action figures rather than
traditional painted cells to animate
their film each character was first
carefully designed hand-built and then
meticulously painted animation was
achieved by moving each figure a
fraction of an inch and photographing
every move frame by frame
the envelope please
oh thank you tear a Wow and the Oscar
goes to Dennis Muren Stan Winston Phil
Tippett and Michael and Terry for
Jurassic Park
you know makes Ireland thanks different
studios